une élue qui met son mandat en jeu hors
élections en plein océan sa plénière le
tout à cause d'une subvention qui tarde
à venir c'était mardi dernier à cluny
bonjour cora bernabé bonjour moïse
vialleton et bonjour aux auditeurs vous
êtes élue d'opposition apm l'aîné vous
êtes également présidente de
l'association 24 on le rappelle
l'association qui promeut cette filière
cacao et vous êtes intervenu en tant que
juge et partie mardi dernier alors une
élue qui intervient pour réclamer des
fonds pour la filière dont elle a la
charge dans le civil s'est tarie ce que
ça bien bien sûr que c'est un risque
mais il y avait aussi un risque que la
filière ben s'écroule parce que on est
dans la ton état dans l'attenté d'une
décision
quant à quant à cette subvention qui
était juste lié à une erreur en fait aux
dépens d'une convention qui avait été
menée enfin écrite sur un an au lieu de
4 on est et on arrivait au bout de
l'échéance je me dis bon ben qu'est ce
que je fais à la fin du mois est ce que
je serai obligé de dire un autre chargé
de mission bien que son contrat ne sera
pas renouvelé ou que que je licencie ou
alors est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on continue
sur la lancée
nous adultes privilégié de pouvoir
intervenir comme son silence lumière oui
mais sur une filière qui a réellement
une opportunité de ceux de se développer
sa démission c'est un coup de bluff
ah non pas du tout et c'était pas
démissionner en ont dans l'assemblée
mais démissionné en tant que présidente
de valco cette décision d' angie
d'alfred marie-jeanne de faire passer le
dossier en consultant conseil exécutif
c'est normalement le cas hier
c'est une décision qui était applaudie
par votre transit quand même assez rare
de voir les élus d'opposition applaudir
le président du conseil exécutif
oui ses reins et je pense en fait que ça
a montré que finalement il n'y avait
peut-être pas de pièces qui manquaient
au dossier comme l'avait précisé le
conseiller exécutif en charge de
l'agriculture la veille et que les
choses allaient être fait dans le sens
de la structuration enfin du maintien de
la structuration de la filière cacao
d'une pierre ducout finalement vous
obtenez gamme creusez vous avez donné un
coup de canif à la majorité pas d'un
coup de canif à la majorité je suis pas
du tout dans une posture de polémique
mais réellement de développement de
notre pays martinique quoi ce dossier
était donc examiné en conseil exécutif
hier vous avez déjà des suites de cette
affaire
je sais qu'il a été étudié je sais qu'il
est passé de façon positive et j'aurai
plus de suite dans la semaine qui arrive
dans votre camp sur les blogs sur les
commentaires d'autres aient lieu pmn on
n'a pas été convaincu même qualifié
l'attitude d' alfred marie-jeanne comme
étendue du cinéma ce matin comment vous
vous ressentez tout sera finalement
après coup ou quelle que soit la façon
dont on qualifie l'attitude ou les
raisons pour lesquelles le président de
l'exécutif a agit aujourd'hui les façons
la le dossier passe je n'aurais
certainement pas à licencier quelqu'un
et pour moi c'est le plus embêtant on a
senti beaucoup d'émotion lors de votre
intervention l'émotion d'une
martiniquaise prête à presque tout
sacrifier pour son pays pour ses
convictions dans ce qu'elle entreprend
c'est selon vous ce qui a séduit le
président du conseil exécutif
je ne sais pas ce qui a séduit le
je suis très attaché à mon pays j'ai
envie de faire des choses pour la
martinique et et tant qu'il me sera
permis en tout cas de pas anticipé à
l'avancé du pays ben je le ferai alors
vous êtes ingénieur agronome pour à
bernabéu envoie le rappelez vous êtes
impliqué dans cette filière cacao
désireuse de reste en martinique venu le
dire de travailler pour votre pays dans
ce secteur car une carte à jouer parce
que cette filière pourrait permettre un
plus grand rayonnement de notre pays
cette filière cacao lundi où exactement
mais aujourd'hui on en est à ce que tous
les producteurs qui ont été formés
1 transformation de fermentation séchage
du cacao maariv a fait un du chocolat
fin à titre de comparaison une tablette
valrhona en épicerie fine chocolats fins
d'un se vend 15 euros les 80 g
on en est à être connue parmi dans les
18 meilleurs mondiaux au salon du
chocolat de paris en a énormément de
demandes on a une demande qui est
supérieur à 100 tonnes annuelles qu'on
ne peut bien sûr pas satisfaire parce
qu'on est aujourd'hui sur un potentiel
de production de l'ordre de 5 à 6 tonnes
alors oui les gens replanté en plus on a
de très bons résultats au bout d'un an
et demi au lieu de trois à cinq ans on
commence à voir des fruits sur l'inde
des cabosses donc on travaille on
continue aussi à travailler avec avec le
pain bain sur l'amélioration de la
qualité la mise en place d'un label
qualité de type aoc iger p donc on
avance c'est quelque chose qui avance
réellement qu est ce qu est ce que vous
aimeriez voir comme production en termes
de tonnage pour la martinique dans les
dix ans à venir dans les dix ans à venir
est elle si on a un niveau 100 150
tonnes c'est possible c'est réalisable
c'est tout à fait réalisable
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait qu est ce qu il
faudrait que les aides à la filière soit
plus importante que les martiniquais ce
roi mieux formés qui aient plus d'
espaces cultivables pour cette
production de cacao
non pas plus d'aces phase d' espaces
cultivables et martinique et mieux
formés on s'en occupe quoi on fait on
fait des formations avec le pain mais
valve kako chaque année pour pouvoir
transmettre finalement ce qu'on a été
recherché le savoir qu'on avait perdu et
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut weeds et dz
mais qu'on ira chercher et qu'on
trouvera pour la stricte pour une
structuration qui soit solide
parlez nous de ce plan de cacao est ce
qu'il est spécificité martiniquaise il
ya vraiment un cacao martiniquais qu'il
faut développer ou mais qu'il faut
continuer à développer par exemple
génétiquement
oui tout à fait on a on s'est rendu
compte qu'en martinique sur les dix
variétés qui existent dans le monde dont
on en a sept qui sont propres à la
martinique et on a une signature
génétique est propre territoire
alors on parle pas dans des mises main
parce que c'est arrivé avec les
amérindiens mais on a une signature
génétique est clair et ce dont on s'est
rendu compte et sion ce sur quoi on va
continuer à travailler
c'est qu'on a des
et des effets terroir un peu comme le
vin est en fonction de l'endroit où on
se situe et quel rôle cacao particulier
au carbure d'autres arrivées avec
exactement enfin en fonction de
l'endroit où on se situe on s'est rendu
compte qu'on n'a pas du tout les mêmes
notes aromatiques donc on a l'a noté
romatique propre au bassin caribéen qui
sont les notes de fruits à coque mais
au-delà de ça on a des notes boisées des
notes de fruits rouges et notes de café
le cacao et va seul à se nourrir de son
environnement
oui exactement faut-il faut-il avec ce
cacao qui est en train de se développer
en martinique visait tout simplement le
marché intérieur ou bien faire comme le
rhum partir à l'assaut à l'assaut des
autres contrées où les deux ouais je moi
je pense qu'il faut faire ce qui se
passe pour la can 1 on a passé deux
cales pour pouvoir satisfaire tout le
monde
alors pour le cacao pour le cacao moi je
pense qu'il faut faire les deux je pense
qu'il faut satisfait un bain au niveau
local parce que je crois que il faut que
les martiniquais puissent profiter de
leurs produits et puis au delà de sa
main pouvoir rayonner à l'international
oui mais lorsqu'on parle de consommation
de chocolat
il faut voir quoi la tablette qu'on a
dans son sac et un petit cours dépendant
un nouveau coup de mou de la poudre
chocolatée au petit déjeuner le matin ou
bien la boîte l'assortiment qu'on va
offrir lorsqu'on part à l'étranger ou
alors aujourd'hui qu'elles sont
incapables de faire qu'est ce que nous
sommes capables de faire aujourd'hui on
a une grosse entreprise qui est une qui
est capable de faire des tablettes de
chocolat on a des shows h et l'eau tout
à fait on à un chocolatier fin le zerg
est capable de faire mais ce que les
chocolats qu'on a en boîte et on
travaille avec eux et du coup oui on est
capable de faire c'est de là le chocolat
en poudre
peut-être pas aujourd'hui parce que ça
demande une autre technologie mais c'est
quelque chose aussi qui sera possible et
le chocolat de première communion qu'on
pourrait exporter
on a commencé un oui pourquoi pas cora
bienabe est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que à travers votre exemple
à travers votre cas personnel vous
pouvez être
une sorte de contre exemples de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui cette jeunesse
martiniquaise qui part parce qu'elle est
n'est pas convaincu par ce qu'elle
pourrait trouver ici en martinique pour
se fixer pour travailler pour développer
le pays
je pense que oui je peux être une sorte
de contre exemple mais met plus un
exemple quoi et dire dire aux jeunes
s'il vous plaît ne partez pas enfin je
j'en discute avec des amis assez souvent
chaque semaine qui ont envie de s'en
aller parce que tout simplement ils ne
trouvent pas de travail ici quoi mais je
pense je pense qu'il faut se battre
parce que si l'opportunité on ne nous la
présente pas sur un plateau d'argent ou
encore une fois je la cherche et qui
est-ce qui répondent à cette jeunesse
qui vous interroge c'est la présidente
de l'association val cac oscille
ingénieur agronome
ou bien c'est l'élu ces corps à berlin
vit tout simplement faim c'est la
personne c'est un tout du coup et oui et
je dis non ne partez pas quoi un restons
ici construisons le pays de demain ne
laissons pas d'autre le faire à notre
place mais vous plus plus que les autres
vous savez quel est ce décalage il ya le
temps politique il y a le temps de
l'autre de l'entrepreneuriat des délais
pour trouver une structure juridique
pour son entreprise pour trouver les
financements et vous savez puisque nous
et nous nous y étions sept semaines vous
savez qu'il y a des délais
administratifs afin de trouver des fonds
qui permettrait de faire quelque chose
oui oui je suis je suis vraiment
vraiment consciente de tout ça je pense
qu'il faut pas baisser les bras quoi
enfin partir ailleurs pour faire quoi
pour qui je pense qu'on pourrait que de
l'expérience pu revenir
oui mais quand on pas en gagner de
l'expérience on a du mal à revenir après
on s'installe et puis et puis les choses
continuent quoi et on a du mal à revenir
s'installer et je pense aussi que les
chefs d'entreprise qu'enfin les
personnes présentes ici en martinique
qui ont la capacité d'employer peut-être
devrait un peu plus faire confiance aux
jeunes quand on regarde les offres
d'emploi souvent on dit minimum 2 ans
d'expérience oui mais je viens d'en
venir je n'ai pas ces deux ans
d'expérience
ben revenez dans deux ans et on revenait
dans cinq ans ou revenait dans dix ans
mais non je pense qu'il faut donner aux
jeunes le en chance aujourd'hui et le
politique dans tout ça
ce qui m'a pas être à travailler
davantage par exemple sur la
simplification des démarches la
transparence de ces démarches la
réduction des délais alors la
simplification des démarches
oui on est dans une règlementation
française qui est ultra compliqué qui
demande énormément de papier et qui
prend énormément finalement les dossiers
prennent énormément de temps à être
traités qu'est ce que vous avez dit
encore simplification transparence dans
les démarches oui par rapport à ça en
termes de communication je pense qu'il
faut qu'il y ait encore un est allé et
fonds a fait un haut niveau de frais de
marie jeanne au deuxième jour de la
plénière
ben certainement certainement les
communications en tout cas sur les aides
qui existent il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui ne sont pas au courant montmagny à
kia qu'il existe des aides au montage
des entreprises qu'il existe même pour
ma part dans l'agriculture d aide au
montage des dossiers agricoles et et
après pour en bénéficier c'est encore
tout tout un problème parce que parce
qu'il faut des bureaux d'études
compétents en la matière etc
il ya toujours une réglementation
particulière des tas de démarches à
accomplir finalement c'est compliqué
alors que la jeunesse elle va chercher
où c'est plus simple oui tout à fait oui
oui c'est doux c'est beaucoup trop
compliqué c'est beaucoup trop compliqué
il faut monter des dossiers on prend des
fois six mois un an a monté un dossier
on le dépose on a la réponse un an deux
ans plus tard on a le temps de jeu
lorsqu'on a une réponse et on a le temps
on a largement le temps de s'effondrer
quoi pourra bien l'habit merci d'avoir
été avec nous on rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de l'association val cacao et
que vous êtes également élu d'opposition
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
c'est de la collectivité territoriale de
martinique merci d'abriter sur la table
mais ainsi ministre
[Musique]